thank you it's so good to be here I've
been traveling around the country
telling jokes drinking white wine uh so
I have no idea how many kids I have out
there no Club hmm
and I don't keep it address for that
reason so I'll never find me
I'm originally from Ohio a lot of people
in Ohio don't realize that you can pull
all of your things into a bag and then
leave
let's get right on out of town and one
of my first Jobs was at a bagel shop so
as you can imagine a lot of times I was
serving bagels straight to my face I
gained a little weight and I took the
job why we all take jobs in food service
for the sexual harassment I worked out
great I think it was around
Christmastime that my boss my boyfriend
my boss he announced that we were having
a weight loss challenge which sounds
illegal so I quit I usually tend to date
potheads it's kind of like my thing I
don't I don't know why you know I guess
I guess they can't leave if they're
already gone
I am currently in a long-distance
relationship so as you can imagine I am
just constantly looking for a new
relationship not really I do fantasize a
lot about strangers let's do I got it
thank you
watching I love my way friend I do don't
get me wrong I love my boyfriend so much
that I went out and I got his name
tattooed on my back and I know a lot of
you guys are thinking
whoops-a-daisy and I've seen Benjamin
Button okay I know things end but a
friend of mine a friend of mine was like
Beth this is truly the worst mistake of
your life what if you date somebody else
and I said point taken you know if I am
dating somebody else from behind and and
they see that tattoo you know I can just
look back and be like hey this is the
kind of commitment you can expect from
me like that'll do it you know it's not
bubble letters and hearts and things
like that it's just a signature so it's
really more of like a lease you know I
like to look at it my mom is very
uncomfortable with anything sexual okay
I think it's cuz she's a virgin
now my mom and I we go way back so um I
have always loved playing little pranks
on her and when I was younger she would
pick me up from school on her mercury
sable her sable tooth tiger and I would
get in the front seat and I would just
be like scoping up the neighborhood for
stragglers you know so I could lean out
the window and just go hey do you need a
ride and then just get down real low you
know so it just looked like my sweet mom
driving the car going no no it was her
first which to that kid just looks like
dolars and know what they told you in
school gamer car and despite my antics
my mom would would roar like she'd
reward me with sweets which haunts her
to this day because my teeth are rotting
out of my head uh she had to buy me a
tooth for Christmas so it was actually a
crown I'm a queen and we used to go to
Dairy Queen all the time together you
guys familiar with DQ got eat school
treats and so I order a Reese's Cup
blizzard and
before they hand you your Blizzard they
like to they just like to turn it upside
down before they give it to you knows if
to be like what you're about to eat is
completely unnatural yeah I see out six
to the cup he's gonna stick to your butt
that's for you we told you and even
though my mom is uncomfortable sexual
thing she makes like quite a bit of it
and invert n't sexual innuendo so then
my mom this day she goes to order and
she leans towards the speaker and she
goes oh yeah
okay I will take a penis brittle purr
and then I said she may need a penis
whether it's brittle or not oh yeah
David